Te duc la locul ăla al meu secret. Nici
peștii n auzi de [râsete]
este.
>> Bravo, tată! Hai că vin acum.
Este. Da,
>> da, da.
>> Nu cred.
>> Vai de capul meu.
>> Na, mă, amâ de
>> Ah!
Mare
>> du ca
>> s a îndreptat cârligul. S a îndreptat
cârligul, mă.
>> Da.
>> N am și n am n am
>> al doilea pește s a îndreptat cârligul.
Este, mă.
>> N am forțat.
>> Am văzut. Am văzut.
>> Deci nu
>> o să mă uit pe cameră.
>> N am nu n am. Te vorbesc serios.
>> N am auzit frâna. Auitâna
>> am dat drumul la frână. Deci
>> Hai, hai, hai să schimbăm cârligul.
Dragi pescari, trăsătura a venit pe ce
credeți?
Eterna căpșună GDA Fishing. Căpșunica.
>> Bă, n n am forțat. Deci n am forțat.
>> Da, mă lasă, stai liniștit. Așa. Nada pe
momitor, ediție specială și căpșunica de
15 mm. Am trecut la 15 mm și cârligul.
Nu ști dacă se vede la voi pe filmare,
dar deja i s a îndoit i s a îndoit
vârful și este un pic este un piccănat.
Ăă, nu l a forțat Mihai, dar fiind un
cârlig subțire, ăă este un cârlig de
opt. Na, se întâmplă chestia asta. Ăă,
am mai prins mai devreme tot cu montura
asta, tot cu cârligul ăsta un pește și
sincer să vă spun nu am verificat
cârligul înainte. Adică nu m am uitat să
văd dacă Asta e o greșeală. E greșeala
mea Mihăiță. Greșeală de începător.
>> Suntem entuziasmați.
>> N am N am verificat cârligul și văd că
vârful cârligului este un pic îndoit.
Oricum schimbăm și dăm din nou. Vedem ce
este neața, dragi pescari, suntem în
Delta Dunării și avem o partidă, nu știu
cum să vă zic,
foarte dificilă și în același timp
foarte bună.
Situația este în felul următor. O să vă
spun lucrurile exact așa cum s au
întâmplat. Clipul acesta nu este
neapărat despre pescuit și este despre
nu este neapărat despre prinde pește, ci
este în general despre pescuit și ce se
întâmplă în Delta Dunării sau ce se
poate întâmpla în Delta Dunării în
partidele noastre de pescuit.
Sunt mulți pescari care, apropo, am
uitat să vi l prezint pe Mihai Manea
care este colegul meu de echipă.
>> Salut.
>> Nu l am băgat în cadru și nu l pun să
discutăm prea mult pentru că am un
singur microfon. Călalt microfon nu
funcționează, din păcate, și atunci o să
vă fac eu prezentarea. Ce voiam să zic
este în felul următor:
Nu vreau să las o impresie greșită prin
clipurile pe care noi le facem cum că în
Delta Dunării trebuie să prinzi pește de
fiecare dată când mergi sau că ai o
frecvență foarte bună atunci când în
partidele de pescuit. Da, pentru că nu
vreau să fac chestia asta, să las
impresia greșită ca oamenii să creadă
cum că dacă cumpără produsele noastre,
ei o să aibă rezultatele pe care le văd
la noi pe cameră. Într adevăr, noi
aproape de fiecare dată avem rezultate
bune, dar ce s a întâmplat în partida
asta a fost complet diferită față de
partidele de partidele anterioare. Am
ajuns de joi în Delta Dunări împreună cu
Mihai și
până astăzi dimineață am scos un singur
ciortan și am mai avut câteva rateuri.
Da, deși colegii noștri pescari, Andrei,
a prins câțiva pești,
Hari a prins câțiva pești, Costeluș a
prins câțiva pești, Sile a prins, Cosmin
a prins,
>> Marian Mincu a prins pești și noi
efectiv parcă am fost urmăriți de
ghinion, în ghilimele urmăriți de
ghinion, pentru că până astăzi nu am
reușit să scoatem pești, deși am stat pe
pești mari, am încercat să pescuim la
pești mari, am încercat toate toate
variantele, tot ce ați văzut în
clipurile mele anterioare. are cu pelete
de 10, cu cârlige de 10. Până la urmă am
pus și pop up micuț de șase. Adică am
încercat absolut toate metodele ca să
provocăm o trăsătură. Am avut pe zi, să
zic, două trei trăsături, scăpări, n am
prins pește, nu i am scos și așa mai
departe. Ideea este în felul următor. Se
poate întâmpla într o partidă să nu
prinzi pește și este perfect normal să
se întâmple chestia asta. Ce pot ce pot
eu să vă recomand și ce pot eu să vă
spun să faceți este să nu renunțați, da?
și să o luați ca pe un s o luați ca pe
un joc, ca pe o provocare. Să vă gândiți
ce ați făcut greșit sau ce puteți face
mai bine sau să aveți încredere în ce
ați făcut
și efectiv să mergeți pe ideea bă n am
făcut nimic greșit și efectiv peștele nu
a trecut prin fața mea, nu s a hrănit în
zona mea am avut adică nu cum să nu
încercăm să dăm vina pe ceva ci efectiv
să încercăm să găsim lucrurile care au
logică. Da, noi ieri, bineînțeles că am
glumit la cazare. Am fost la Marian
Mincu la Gigant Fici la pensiune și am
tot glumit că Mihai este piază rea, că
el n a prins pește, că e cu ghinion
pentru că a tot scăpat, a tot încercat
să înțepe și nu știu ce. Dar na, astea
au fost glumele noastre. Este clar că nu
a fost vorba de de treaba asta. Acum
dimineața am ajuns cred că pe la 7:00 și
ceva eram cu bețele în apă. După ce ne
am poziționat pe cioată, am aruncat
peste cioată, deci ne am pus, ne a
recomandat asta Cosmin a zis: "Băieții,
încercați, el a prins așa aprins peșter,
a zis: "Încercați să vă puneți să vă
poziționați în stuf și să dați peste
cioată. Nu mai dați până niciodată și
încercați și așa. Nu pot să zic că
neapărat ăsta este motivul pentru care
am prins, dar este posibil ca motivul să
fie că am scăpat noi așa un pic de
ghinionul nostru și
am avut un pic mai multă încredere în
ceea ce facem și au venit și la noi
câțiva pești, de fapt două pești, două
trăsături, unul l am scos, unul unul a
fost ratat. Și cine credeți că l a
ratat?
>> Vezi că tu e rândul tău să tragi acuma.
Mihai, tot mihai, dar pescuim cu cârlige
de opt. Acum avem cârlige de opt cu
pelete de 15 mm și v am arătat mai
devreme pe video sau nu știu cum o să
montez video. Cârligul s a îndreptat un
pic și
oricum vârful cârligului era deja
îndoit. Eu nu l am verificat că a venit
peștele pe aceeași lansetă pe care am
scos la care am scos peștele și nu l am
verificat înainte să lansez din euforie,
din chestii de genul ăsta și posibil ca
eu să l fi lucrat pe Mihai așa un pic.
Regula la noi în barcă este în felul
următor. Nu știu dacă v am mai spus asta
pe cameră.
Un pește cu un pește, da, o trăsătură
unul, o trăsătură altul. Peștele care
este prins în barcă este prins de
amândoi pescari este prins de echipă.
Da. Îl pozăm amândoi. Amândoi ne lăudăm
în ghilimele cu el pentru că este
peștele nostru. Da. Na, norocul face ca
unul să fie când e un pește mare și
altul să fie când e un ciordan. Asta e,
nu, Mihai?
>> Asta e.
>> Și atunci peștele este e Peștele este la
amândoi. Peștele este al echipei, deci
nu contează cine l a scos. Da, deși unii
e o ghinion. [râsete]
Bun, noi astăzi, astăzi este duminică,
mai avem câteva ore de pescuit. O să mai
stăm maxim o oră, oră și jumătate pe
locul acesta. Dacă nu avem o trăsătură,
o să ne mutăm în alt loc. Oricum, pește
este foarte mult. Am văzut o grămadă de
pește pe toate canalele pe care am fost.
Nu vă zic că ne am mutat.
Am pescuit până și pe sulina, am pescuit
pe mai multe canale, ne am dus, am
căutat, adică oricum a fost o vânjoleală
maximă. Oamenii au prins așa în jurul
nostru trei patru pești. Trei patru
pești și noi n am avut n am avut pești
prinși și am intrat așa într o pasă
proastă un pic. când ne am revenit și
până la urmă am reușit să scoatem și noi
un superb, superb crap de 11 kg, 700 cu
tot cu cap de mincioc. Mihai zice că are
capul de mincioc fiind subțire și din
aluminiu are 200 de g, dar eu am zis că
peștele, na, până la urmă are 11 kg ca
să fie să fie o cifră rotundă. Deci un
crab de 11 kg prins pe canale în Delta
Dunării, ceea ce din punctul meu de
vedere este o raritate. Da, am reușit să
facem treaba asta. Suntem fericiți.
>> Acuma acum am dat drumul la filmare.
Neața, dragi pescar. 7:00 dimineața.
Delta Dunării. E un frig de îngheață
pietrele.
A venit
Ghita mai mustăcios. Ia uitați
>> vă superleuu.
>> Canale Delta Dunării Gda Fishing.
Băieți,
ia uitați vă.
>> Am făcut zoom pe el.
Ia uite cu mine. Dă repede ia uite cu
mine torpida pe băiat.
Ia uitați vă, dragi pescari, în Delta
Dunării. Nu intră, nu intră minciog.
Hai, Mihăiță, trage l.
>> Incredibil, incredibil.
Hai, hai, hai, hai.
Zic că are Da, cam 11 cred că are.
Doamne ferește, cât animalul. Hai repede
să facem poză.
>> Da, scoate l pentru că o să i facem o să
i facem filmare.
>> O să i facem eliberare.
O să facem un lucru pe care îl vedeți
foarte rar, din păcate. O să facem o
eliberare a unui pește de 11 kg. Un
exemplar superb.
Îl eliberăm pentru că vrem să se
înmulțească și vrem să dăm un exemplu
pescarilor, să facă și ei la fel ca noi.
Măcar pe cei mari să elibereze. Hai,
Mihăiț!
Gata,
11 kg pe canale, băieți. 11 kg este. Mă,
haideți să vă mai prezint, să vă mai
prezint o dată montura și să vă zic ce
am făcut acum. Am pescuit cu pelete de
15. Bine, am tot încercat cu 10 pelete
de 10 și cu babanele, cum v am zis mai
devreme, peștele peștii au intrat, cele
două trăsături au fost pe pelete de 15
de căpșună. Da. Și haideți să vă arăt ce
i fac eu pe apă rece ca să să se
activeze și mai repede. Deci, efectiv o
ciumovesc, sper că se vede pe cameră
bine, o ciumpovesc cu cuțitul sau cu un
cutter pe toate părțile. Iau așa, iau
păjțat de deasupra ca să se activeze mai
repede. Iar la momitor, prima dată iau o
cantitate de nadă în mână. O frământ
bine, o pun pe momitor, o strâng foarte
bine să rămână acolo, după care vin mai
iau nadă,
iau mai puțină nadă și o pun pe momitor
deasupra superficial, da? Cât să nu cadă
la impactul cu apa, dar să ajungă pe
substrat și când ajunge pe substrat se
desfacă mai repede decât cea care este
dedesubt, da? Ca să se elibereze mai
repede particulele, să provoc mai repede
trăsătura în cazul în care peștele trece
pe acolo. Și acuma ce fac?
Fac o mică gaură cu degetul. Bag peleta
deasupra. Cirașa de pe tort. V am mai
zis de ce se numește cirașa de pe tort.
Pentru că arată ca o cireașă. Da,
o bag. Nu, n o bag foarte mult în
interior pentru că eu vreau că în cazul
în care peștele vine rapid la momitor să
poat să tragă peleta de aici. Deci n o
bag adânc în momitor. Da. Așa. Am băgat
o. Mai strâng un pic la ochi. Așa. O
simt cât să să fiu sigur că nu mi se
desface la impactul cu apa. Da. Și asta
este prezentarea perfectă din punctul
meu de vedere. Da,
așa au venit trăsăturile. Știți că eu
așa pescuiesc. Asta este montura pe care
eu o fac. Și acuma voi lans
[muzică]
de o oră și jumătate n am mai avut nicio
trăsătură. Ne schimbăm, ne ducem pe un
alt loc. Avem un loc puțin mai jos. Ieri
este un loc nădit. Ieri din disperare l
am și nădit cu bile. I a dat Mihai bile
cum trebuie și să încercăm și acolo să
vedem dacă dacă o să avem acolo vreo
tăsătură. Dacă n avem nici acolo într o
oră jumătate poate ne mutăm iar. Nici nu
știu. O să vedem. Dar încercăm să
încercăm să mai provocăm câteva
trăsături. A
>> scos o scoică din
>> Mihai a scos o carapace de scoică. Na,
asta e. Hai, Mihă, hai să ne mutăm.
Dragi pescari, am terminat partida. Ne
am oprit la Costeluci. ne a invitat să
bem o cafea pentru că eram înghețați de
pe drum. Ne am oprit la Gorgova, bem o
cafea și facem închiderea aici acestui
episod pentru că pe barcă începuse
ploaia, n am mai apucat să filmăm.
Oricum n am mai avut nici trăsături și
și
partida. Din punctul meu de vedere a
fost una dintre cele mai grele partide
pe care am avut o până acum în Delta
Dunării. Am alergat mult după pește, am
găsit peștele și efectiv timp de trei
zile, hai să zic două zile și jumătate,
nu am reușit să l păcălim cu absolut
nimic. cu toate momelile pe care noi le
avem, cu toate șmecheriile pe care noi
le știm, cu cârlige micuțe, cu cârlige
mari, cu boiless uri, cu vierme, cu
absolut tot, absolut tot. Nu a vrut să
nu a vrut să se hrănească în timpul
acesta.
Costeluș
a croșetat câțiva peștișori,
>> două doi, trei pe zi, așa, 5 6 kg luat.
A luat
>> curgea iarbă foarte multă, că vântul ne
a omorât vântul. Deci de joi, joi,
vineri, sâmbătă, azi e duminică, acuma s
a mai lăsat acum.
>> Dar patru zile a bătut.
>> A bătut
>> rafale 70 de km/h. Ne a rupt.
>> S a S a și răcit apa. Culme, în loc să
se încălzească apa s a răcit
>> și peștele destul de apatic. Nu a vrut
să se hârnească. Într adevăr, s a mai
prins ceva pește. Andrei Chirciu a avut
o partidă bunică. A prins un pește de 9
kg. A prins și de 7 kg și de trei și de
patru. Și Cosmin a prins ieri.
>> Și Cosmin a prins. A prins ieri. Aici în
partida asta mi am dat seama că mai ține
puțin și de noroc. Pescarul trebuie să
aibă și un pic de noroc. De ce vă spun
treaba asta? Ieri am pescuit lângă lângă
Andrei și lângă Cosmin. Da, Cosmin a
venit mai târziu pe canalul pe care noi
îi pescuiam. Cosmin Andrei a luat trei
crapi frumoși ieri. Noi nu noi am avut
doar două trăsături și n am scos niciun
pește. Iar Cosmin a venit la ora 2:00 și
a luat și el trei pești. Cel mai mare
fiind de 7 kg. Da. Și locul nostru cred
că de departe era cel mai bun dintre
dintre locurile de pe canalul respectiv
cu cioată. Mă rog, erau mai multe cioate
acolo, era și cioată din mal, era și
cioată cumva pe mijloc și am abordat
cioata aia din toate pozițiile la un
moment dat.
>> Eu dimineața lu am, în fiecare dimineață
la ora 6:00 aveam 1 2 1 2
>> după care toată ziua liniște totală.
Costela dormea în, mă rog, el doarme în
cabinată și ne trimitea video dimineață
la 6:00. Hai, mă, ați băut cafeaua, hai
că a început peștele. Până ajungeam noi,
nu, nu, nu se mai hrănat.
>> Bine, au mai avut și vreo patru, cinci
trăsături. Unul l a scăpat frumușel la 6
7 kg l a adus până lângă barcă.
>> Le am văzut filmare
>> așa. Am mai scăpat și eu unul. S a mai
băgat vreo doi înciodată.
>> Da,
>> a fost activitate.
>> Da, activitatea a fost. Activitatea a
fost. Mie, pentru mine, a fost o partidă
grea pentru că nu am avut trăsăturile pe
care eu le așteptam să le am într un
final, astăzi, după ce probabil am
scăpat de ghinioane, eu știu, nu știu ce
s a întâmplat, am reușit să scoatem un
pește de 11 kg.
Pentru mine este un record pe canale și
cred că
>> peste 11, 11 plus, să zicem, 11700
cântărit cu tot cu cap de mincioc și
capul de minciioc, na, e un cap de
mincioc mic.
Este un pește mare pentru canale din
punctul meu de vedere. Se prinde rar
pește mare pe canale. Pentru mine este
un record pe canale. Drilul a fost
superb. Ne a salvat partida din toate
punctele de vedere. Faptul că am prins
peștele ăsta, Mihai, a fost demențial.
Deci cum am mult cei mici, mai bine unul
și bun.
>> Exact. Unul și bun și cam aia a fost.
>> Și a mai avut unul cred că la fel de
mare și s a s a dezduit. Da,
>> da. Dar cu ce
>> cu ce cârlige? M câtigul era de opt, dar
acuma cred eu că am făcut o greșeală în
drillul în drillul anterior. A fost
exact a fost pe aceeași lansetă că eu n
am forțat deloc. Deci am dat drum, am
înțepat doar, am luat lanseta, am dat
drumul la frână aproape
>> liberă, doar am ținut firul întins și
>> oricum oricum o să vedem pe cameră
pentru că drillul lui Mihai este filmat
sau mă rog când a O să vedem
>> al meu al meu este filmat de Mihai cu
telefonul că nu scosesem camerele, nu mi
făcuse nimic. O să oricum voi ați văzut
deja chestia asta pentru că deja am
montat clipul și am pus acolo.
Eu am greșit acolo pentru că n am
verificat cârligul. Din euforia aia, hai
să dăm repede, a venit trăsătura pe
aceeași lansetă și când m am uitat la
cârlig era un dezdit, dar nu de tot. Era
un pic dezdoit și vârful era strâmb,
vârful cârligului era strâmb. Probabil
că nu s a înțepat bine, după care am mai
avut o trăsătură pe o altă lansetă, dar
nu a plecat cu ea.
>> Bun, de miercuri se încălzește, trebuie
să ieșim la pescuit. De miercuri se
încălzește. Dacă se încălzește și avem
crește temperatura apei cu puțin, o să
fie o să fie o să fie foarte bine pentru
pescarii care ies la pescuit. Costeluș,
eu știu, poate și Mihai. Eu din păcate n
am cum să ies.
>> Nici eu nu să mai ies.
>> Dar na, asta este ce vreau să subliniez
și ce am spus și la începutul clipului,
ăsta este pescuitul în Delta Dunării.
Este imprevizibil și nu știu, poate că
pe mine mă credeți, nu mă credeți, dar
am aici lângă mine doi pescari foarte
buni de Delta Dunării. Costeluș este un
pescar vechi de deltă și cei care vă
uitați acum mulți îl cunoașteți deja.
Mihai Mane la fel. Și ei confirmă că
sunt partide și partide și că nu în
fiecare partidă se prinde pește așa cum
noi ne așteptăm. Da. O frecvență foarte
bună sau lucruri de genul ăsta. Și
>> eu am avut trăsături și la Băilesa.
>> Da.
>> Pe Sulina de exemplu cu Delta Activ. Am
avut trăsătură. Am prins un ciortan mic.
N am stat decât patru ore.
>> Colegii noștri au avut ciortan după
ciortan la Delta Activ pe sulina pe
navigabil, dar până în 2 kg.
>> Până în 2 kg. Peștele mare n a fost n a
fost bă nu se efectiv parcă nu puteai să
l păcălești peștele mare.
>> Uite și pent pe tinsură. Chiar și la
momentul ăsta pe tinură sunt niște
băieți prind, dar tot de ăștia
>> ăștia mici ăștia mici ăștia s mai
agresivi. Ăștia s mai agresivi în
creier. Ăștia sunt exact înaintea
momeni.
>> Peștii mari foarte greu îi păcălești,
mai ales în perioada asta, din punctul
meu de vedere. Oricum asta este
pescuitul. Asta ne place. Ne place
provocarea. Mie unul îmi place
provocarea. Ne am aplicăm. Ne am plimbat
pe toate canalele, am luat toate
canalele, am vorbit cu mulți pescari, am
format teorii 200 de l de benzină.
>> Costelușinat a băgat mulți litri de
benzină. Noi mai puțin, ca noastră
consumă mai puțin.
>> Da. Bun. Ce să vă zic, asta a fost
partida. O partidă, un episod scurt
pentru voi, pentru că n au fost foarte
multe drilluri. Foarte multe. Na, hai să
nu ducem foarte multe, dar n au fost
multe drilluri încât să putem filma.
Nici noi nu am avut chef prea mare să
filmăm fără săț mel
>> Da. Uite, o să pot să pot să pun pe pe
clip și cu Costeluș ce a mai prins el,
ce au mai prins și băieții. Câteva poze
>> la Vasile, de la Cosmin, de la Andrei,
de la Harry, tot am fost Noi am fost un
grup mai mare de pescari. Ne am întâlnit
cu toții la Marian Mincu, la Gigan Fish,
care apropo îi mulțumim că ne a găzduit
acolo și cu toții am pescuit fiecare pe
diferite canale. Unul s a dus acolo,
unul s a dus acolo. A fost mai mult de
socializare partida asta. Ne am întâlnit
cu toții pe apă. Dacă ar fi fost după
mine și după Mihai, am fi amânat încă o
săptămână pentru că, na, a fost frig, a
plouat și
>> da, ar fi fost mai bine de miercuri.
>> Da, exact asta este. Ăsta este
pescuitul. Până la urmă am salvat
partida, a fost totul ok. Nu am ieșit
lampă în Delta Dunării. Da, deci nu este
partid de lampă. S a s a trecut. S a
trecut prin A încercat, a avut un o
cutie de chibrituri și la ultimul băț.
>> La ultimul băț. Exact, la ultimul bă s a
aprs.
>> Ultimul băt s a aprins ăsta. S a aprins
un minut, după care s a stins imediat și
n a mai reușit
>> nici cu benzină să l mai aprindă. Se
stingea. Bun, dragi pescari, mulțumesc
frumos că ați urmărit până la sfârșit și
nu uitați să dați acolo un follow și
dacă v a plăcut clipul să l shareuiți și
cu alți prieteni de ai voștri. Vă salut
și vă doresc firi întinds.
>> Salutare.